it's cool bro also yo how did I not make
your top 10 list last year bro it's cool
which top 10 list top 10 rappers or top
10 albums
damn both iron magnesium
it's kind of cool by the way I just
I mean I just did I didn't think you had
I mean it was a good year last year I
didn't think you had a top 10 album last
year I think you had about a top 20.
okay I'll respect that you and on the
rap and [__] I just think the rapping
list was tough man because there was a
lot oh brother there was a lot of
rapping
this [__] Kev
I didn't put Ransom on my list listen I
did put 30. I put 38 specials too though
because 38 Special A little five
you don't know 38 specials trust come on
bro come on bro what you got to do some
[__] with her what a lot of luck Hey
listen a lot of love to everybody bro
I'm not I just I didn't even know until
he told me he's like yo you know he told
me right before we walked in you know
you ain't can't make care of top ten
yeah it's football it's cool a lot of
people didn't make my top 10 lists that
are my friends Benny The Butcher didn't
make the top 10 list I think Conway
might have snuck in I don't think he did
though I actually don't think he did
he might have
but there was a lot of rappers that did
not make the top 10 list I because I put
guys like my thing was last year like I
put a guy like Simba on the list because
Simba did the rapper [__] last year that
[__] hit every Outlet he had
moments on these [__] he like when I
saw Simba like
yo I'm trying to make sure y'all see me
as that [__] so I'm gonna go rap
everywhere
and he put out a cool project now
Simba's mad because I didn't put his
project in the top ten but I didn't tell
him the same thing hey it wasn't a top
10 album love you you're on my top 10.
hey I gotta respect it bro yeah you okay
what do you think about this you think
the average music consumer
wants to be a Critic or likes or like
wants to be of of influence not like I I
think we're losing a pool of like people
that are just genuine music fans like me
bro I'm just a genuine music right I
remember this one artist dropped the
song and the fans were like
yo the song was good but this makes his
ass like what the [__] do you know about
a mix you know what I'm saying I think
it's too many like you can come I think
a lot of people like yourself right you
can comment on music because you've been
you've done the research you've been
doing this [__] for a long time you've
been around you've done the research the
history the knowledge
like a lot of these kids be putting out
hot takes and all of this [__] no
information that's just social media
though yeah that's true so it's just
like everyone has opinion about
everything everything so it's not even
music it's like everyone thinks that
they're political experts yeah everybody
thinks that they're [__] Skip Bayless
or their [__] Sports these
[__] don't know [__] like I was
sitting
with some Phoenix Suns fans that I'm
related to in Arizona not too long ago
and with a straight face they try to
tell me that we made the right decision
to draft DeAndre Aiden over Luka donkic
and I'm like well you just don't watch
basketball and you're a [__] loser
and never talk to me about sports again
that was crazy see you at Christmas you
[__] what is that [__] DeAndre Aiden
doing now you know he's just getting
rebounds and you know not dunking
despite being seven feet tall I hope you
trade his [__] ass God bless him hey
black man get money I'm proud of you dog
me too let's I'd like to trade him for
another black man getting money
yeah I'm just saying